merci monsieur le Président
ma question s'adressait à Madame pagnès
Agnès
depuis un an notre pays traverse une
crise énergétique effroyable le
gouvernement allume bien sûr des
contrefeux nous avons entendu quelques
explications bouclier tarifaire
amortisseur filet de sécurité 24
milliards d'euros en 2022 43 milliards
en 2023 l'échec comme mode de
gouvernement sont très dangereux vous le
savez financé par de la dette mal
calibrée complexe dans leur exécution
insuffisant toujours insuffisant à
défaut de solutions structurelles vous
arrosez le sable avec de l'eau la
solution structurelle elle est
européenne car nous sommes aujourd'hui
prisonniers de l'architecture européenne
du prix d'électricité Lyon électricité
gaz charbon madame la ministre l'état de
guerre a pulvérisé le marché énergétique
la disparition du gaz russe la
déséquilibrer profondément et
probablement définitivement
il faut donc tirer les conséquences de
cet état de fait et abolir immédiatement
les mécanismes de concurrence qui
génèrent l'architecture du prix de
conseils européens en Conseil européen
nous ne voyons rien venir nous ne voyons
rien bouger à défaut pour la France
d'avoir le poids désormais suffisant en
Europe pour faire bouger les choses
demander des dérogations immédiates
d'autres l'ont fait y compris dans des
pays où l'interoparabilité est forte
madame la ministre c'est urgent on ne
peut plus attendre les prochains
conseils européens notre économie ne le
supportera pas merci de nous dire votre
action